and the spirit award for best female
performance new scripted series
goes to
[Music]
tuso bedu
this is tuso and bedu's first nomination
and first win
the underground railroad is executive
produced by spirit award-winning
director barry jenkins
this series is based on the novel of the
same name which was written by coulson
whitehead
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh snap um
they told me a number of times to
prepare something and i really didn't um
but
first and foremost thank you
to film independent for this recognition
uh barry jenkins thank you for
absolutely everything
um
i really really really appreciate you
francine maisler because i met you
before i met barry
thank you thank you thank you for your
guidance thank you to
amazon to all the executive producers
to my team both april lori
everyone else from
my sister
in south africa
she would kill me if i didn't say
anything about her appreciate all the
support and
every single person who was involved in
the underground railroad there was no
person who was too small in making the
project what it was and i really really
hope that you guys will take the time to
watch it because it's an absolute
masterpiece
thank you very much
[Music]
you